more than 3 million people have fled the
war in ukraine and that number is
growing mike armstrong has more on why
leaving or staying are both risky
options
these are images released by an aide to
the ukrainian president they are
refugees being picked up from two cities
in the central part of the country and
taken to safer areas of the ten
humanitarian corridors open on this day
two led to the city of bravery just east
of kiev
stories from that city's hospital help
explain the challenge and the danger of
trying to get around this man was shot
three times
he says he's a civilian and was
traveling in a civilian vehicle russian
soldiers he says shot through his
windshield
if moving is dangerous so is staying put
in a place like mariupol right now it
means more misery every day
this woman just escaped
this woman says she spent 10 days in a
cellar hiding from bombs and didn't
leave once they had no electricity and
no running water
in the town of zaparica a grocery store
is turned into a refugee center many of
the people in it left mariupol and
consider themselves lucky
this man says anyone who could leave did
but many didn't make it they drove by
bombed and burned out cars on their way
out of town there were bodies he says in
the streets
now this is where so many want to go
west to poland of the more than 3.2
million refugees who fled ukraine about
two-thirds have crossed into poland
this mother of five says by the time she
decided to leave her home west of keeve
with her children there was no food and
no way to stay
on this day among those crossing over
was a woman whose destination is canada
she'd been on vacation was home in
ukraine visiting her parents from
studying sociology in canada when the
war broke out she didn't regret being
there actually i'm kind of really glad
that i could go here even though it's
like it's real terrible right now but at
least i could see my parents because i
don't know it's gonna be
she says right now her future is hard to
worry about she's safe in poland her
thoughts are all about her parents who
stayed behind
mike armstrong global news czech poland